yo what is up everybody man Luigi cute
some more fallout 4 content now today
I'm gonna be showing you guys how to get
your very own hazmat suit that has a
radiation resistance of 1000 you heard
me right one zero zero zero
you can kiss a radiation goodbye because
you're never gonna get anything above
less than one rads if you have this suit
on and as you can see I'm just in a bit
of radiation and I'm only getting less
than one note drinking ready and water
still makes you take brands so let's get
into this video without any further ado
so what you're going to do is head up
into the North East part of the map
exactly where I am you come near the
Museum of witchcraft just right there
head on over there as close as you can
and once you get around the area area
that you want to be at you're going to
find a little nuclear symbol on your
mini-map or your HUD and you're gonna
follow that you're gonna see this quarry
that you can see on the screen and
you're gonna follow this um follow the
radiation basically since the farther
you go in the more it's radiated it's
gonna be there's gonna be a lot of traps
so these are pretty easy to get rid of
just disarm them all there's gonna be a
turret that's pretty weak so just chew
that down and once you get through all
of this it isn't too long so you guys
should be okay once you get the roll of
that you'll find Hugo's pole which is
the point you're going to and you're
gonna find the hazmat suit right on the
best fit you can't equip this while you
have power armor on cuz you can't change
your smaller armor while you have power
armor however this does work in tandem
with power armor so if you have the
hazmat suit and the power armor then you
get the a thousand radiation and then
you still have the armor from the power
armor since the hazmat suit does removes
all of your other armor and has no other
values of than a thousand radiation
resistance and you can see I was picking
up some rads but earlier when I passed
these barrels go back over them it's
less than one also my last clip you'll
see I'll run around that crater I was in
without any clothes on and you'll see me
get crazy radiation so hope you guys
enjoyed this quick little guide and how
to get your very own hazmat suit which
is very beneficial especially if you're
wandering into the clothing scene where
I am in this video and thank you for
watching guys I really appreciate it if
you like this stuff and you want to see
or this stuff check out more of my
channel thanks for watching again peace
out